welcome back before we say goodbye we
like to play a quick round up truth or
dare
today we have logan johnson hi logan hi
drew hi hi how are you thank you i'm
good i wanted to thank you both for
everything you do the show is so
beautiful and it's my daily dose of joy
thank you so much oh
thank you so much
is it going to be a truth or a dare it's
going to be a dare okay
we've never said no before so bring it
on okay you ready yeah i love sour foods
i dare you to eat a quarter of a lemon
while keeping a total poker face
i love this dare do you have a lemon
someone does
oh oh
we just found some on the desk okay
three two go
[Music]
oh god i failed
i now want to see more people do this
and see who can and can't because it was
impossible not to make the pickle phase
it's a new a tick tock challenge try it
at home try it let's start one let's do
it let's do it right now yeah
lemon face
we do
we challenge you to a tick tock
challenge can you eat a lemon and keep a
straight face
i'll tell you i couldn't do it mm-hmm
let's see what are you doing see if this
happens thank you so much logan
and thank you for your kind word really
and truly
because that is actually the whole point
i just want to thank everyone for
choosing to spend their time with us
because to logan's point we make this
show for you
so take it with you and thank you so
much for coming everybody
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you